hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for you and aspiring software engineers
and today we are talking about the very
controversial topic of if you need a
computer science degree and so this
video is not going to be a
debate eve video of oh you need a
computer science no you don't excellency
like no it's not going to be debating
it'll be me laying down the facts to
help you specifically you decide if you
need or want to pursue a computer
science degree in hopes of becoming a
software developer or just a person in
tech in general so yeah if you're
looking for a commentatory video this is
not it so
bye okay so for those of y'all who
stayed so first i'm going to talk about
computer science as a major as a degree
in general so what is the goal of a
computer science degree the goal is for
you to develop problem solving skills
through the use of algorithms and
operating systems you'll practice your
problem solving skills through things
like homework tests team and individual
projects and even things like research
papers you as a major will dive deep
into things like computational finance
robotics and even network security and
so you can really cover a lot and you
know with four years i would hope you
would cover a lot and so yes it's less
of a thing of oh i must learn javascript
for front-end development instead you're
really touching multiple different parts
of computer science and development now
going on to languages so the types of
languages you can expect to learn as a
computer science major include languages
like java c and c plus plus php
python and javascript those five are
typically the go-to
starter pack of a computer science major
you should also expect additional
coursework in subjects like calculus
statistics linear algebra and other math
related subjects and so all in all after
getting a cs degree you definitely are
well set up for a starter job at a
company now to get into whether you
specifically you should get the degree
or not we're going to discuss some
things that you should know at least
consider
before making that decision one of the
things is to kind of have an
understanding of what you're trying to
do and where you're trying to be in
general if you are fully aware that you
want to work in a.i and you see that
there are no outside programs to help
you do that and really the best choice
for you is to go into a computer science
degree major school master's program x y
and z then definitely i'm not here to
tell you no that is not my goal here but
if your goal is to be in the tech field
or you know you want to be a developer
but you're not sure if you should focus
on front end or back end or what
languages that you really want to work
with then that's where the conversation
should really really start because it is
my opinion that you definitely should
not go into computer science with the
idea that is your only way to get there
so if you don't believe me let me go
into this real quick let me bring on
some knowledge to y'all so there are
insane
top companies that
don't look for degrees when making their
hiring decisions if you don't believe me
let's see if you recognize some of these
google
apple
ibm
facebook
pinterest
airbnb
ebay and even linkedin yeah none of
these companies require their
programmers to have degrees and if that
shocks you if that list of companies
shocks you with oh really they they
don't require a degree think about this
there are companies on this list and i'm
sure we all know that
their founders
dropped out of college
to start these companies
yeah so wouldn't it be kind of insane to
now require me to have a degree because
that would kind of take me off a little
bit not gonna lie now there were many
many years where some if not all of
these companies did require their
programmers to have degrees however from
what i have read it was more of a
reading out tool you can imagine the
amount of people applying to their roles
and so they wanted some way to make the
job of looking through applicants easier
and one of those ways is by reading
people out well what's a very simple
easy way to weed someone out well
disqualify them for not having a degree
i don't like it i don't like it and it
looks like y'all didn't like it because
they realized that that was not the
right way to go because some of the most
brilliant people again so some of them
dropped out of college and don't have
college degrees yet here they are and so
yes if your goal is to be an employee
developer and employed software engineer
know that you don't need a degree to get
there don't seek a computer science
degree with the mindset of because i
won't get a job without one now that
being said where things get iffy and
tricky is getting a major in computer
science does prepare you well for
technical interviews because a lot of
these companies and companies in general
have the technical interview portion of
their recruiting process and that is
really where a lot of reading out
happens because a lot of people who
self-taught or into coding boot camps
they're not well versed in data
structures and algorithms and so that's
really where things can bite them even
if they can do the job they see that
they couldn't get past the technical
interview portion don't let that
discourage you by the way because i saw
this article that said a huge amount of
the very people giving you the technical
interview at these top fame companies
they themselves cannot solve the problem
without months and months of preparation
so don't think that oh because i didn't
actually get a degree and i got you know
a certificate instead or went to coding
bootcamp or self-taught
me figuring out all this data structure
stuff is not going to work like no even
if you got that degree honey it would
take you months months and months and
months of preparation when i say months
i don't mean one to two months i mean up
to a year yeah people study for up to a
year for interviews in these top
companies and so don't let that
discourage you it's not because you
don't have a computer science degree
it's because you need to make sure
you're really laying down the groundwork
making sure that you're well versed and
taking the amount of time it's going to
take for you to pass those rounds and so
yes i did want to make sure i pointed
that out that way i'm not getting hate
mail or anything because you failed your
interview because you didn't prepare
like that's not my fault and so yes it's
not because you didn't get a computer
science degree it's because of the back
end tail end preparation that you need
to do anyway and so overall computer
science degrees are great for providing
you that insight into multiple different
languages multiple different concepts
and spheres in which you can use your
knowledge your technical knowledge
however where they lack is providing you
with newer and more up-to-date skill
sets and practice with languages for
example let's say you know you want to
be a front-end developer well odds are a
computer science degree isn't going to
provide you with classes where you can
really dive deep into bootstrap and
react and creating very sleek and
functioning web apps or mobile apps and
so that's where
things can kind of get iffy however what
they do teach you is how to learn how to
program because once you know how to
code like one to two languages oh the
whole world opens up for you and so even
though you want to be in front end just
you knowing let's say python now you'll
be able to learn javascript much easier
now that you know javascript you'll be
able to learn react much easier and all
of that and so they provide you with
that baseline of okay this is how you
quote program and hopefully now that you
know these x amount of languages you'll
be able to go off into the world like
that but if you know you want to learn a
specific language and a specific skill
and you see the coursework and yeah the
computer science degree the computer
science program doesn't teach that then
yeah that's when it's like
i'm good personally i'm good and so yes
that's where the decision-making comes
in if you do want to become a developer
but yeah don't want to go through the
years of a computer science degree there
are so many options for you you can go
to the self-teaching route there's so
many free free resources out there for
you like free code camp is right there
in the name free code camp you can
really start dabbling in coding and
seeing what languages you like and if
you even like the coding process in
general then you can slowly rise up to
more paid but still extremely discounted
when you think about the cost of college
tuition places like udemy edx new to me
i got like five courses for ten dollars
each because they're always having a
grand sale that that's a conversation
for a different date all these grand
sales like just tell me your cost is ten
dollars total all the time but that's a
conversation for a different day so yes
udemy edx codecademy there are just so
many resources out there for you if you
see that you are the type that needs a
teacher but again you don't want to go
through these four years three years
getting a degree in computer science
then you can go the coding bootcamp
route and just because you're at a
coding bootcamp doesn't mean you won't
get the necessary skills needed the
actually coding bootcamp what's amazing
is they really really go and fine-tune
the specific skills needed so that you
can complete the course complete the
program in just a matter of months and
be employable afterwards and these
coding bootcamps they have very close
tied relationships with employers and so
they stay in that constant communication
with them trying to see what they look
for in their developers what languages
they want their developers to know and
they use that to build their curriculum
and so no
coding bootcamp is a very great way to
get into the field especially quickly
now of course they have their own things
going on oh all of these things have
their pros and cons i have a couple of
videos to go through all those things so
i'll link them down below but i'm just
telling you you have options don't
attend college because you think that's
the only way you'll get somewhere attend
college because you want to attend it
because you want to learn about
computational finance and you want to do
the algorithm prep and learn about all
these different spheres of computer
science while also having that student
life and all of this go to college for
that a thousand percent like i will
cheer you on i'll drive you there no no
i will i will drive you there but no i
will be cheering you on but i'm just
saying that's why i created this video
so that you understood that there are
options to getting into this field so
you may realize that you need a computer
science degree and so that's the point
of this video not do you does the
general you need a computer science
degree to be a software engineer to be a
developer because my answer is no
straight up no but hopefully this video
helped you see whether or not you
need one so there we go everybody please
like and subscribe and i hope i answered
some questions for you if i didn't
please leave them down below please
please and i'll talk to you all later
bye